new government data shows nearly twenty
nine million Americans do not have
health insurance 22 million of those who
do have medical insurance use Aetna it
is the third largest provider in the
country but that number could soar if
regulators and shareholders approve
CVS house sixty nine billion dollar
acquisition of the health insurer CVS
has more than ten thousand pharmacies in
clinics across the country those could
soon become one-stop shops for
preventative care treatment and filling
prescriptions Mark Bertolini is chairman
and CEO of Aetna he's with us at the
table welcome back this is but this be
the largest American health insurance
deal in history is that right I think so
the largest ever okay so the question is
how is it going to change the way I get
health care well I think in the health
care industry we've got things backwards
what we do is we sell health insurance
first and I use an analogy being a
Detroit boy of buying an automobile you
don't go to GMAC to buy a car they
finance cars health insurers are really
fine answers of health care we go to a
dealership talk about our ambitions for
our transportation what is it we want
and then we go finance it later on but
in health care we finance everything
first we get a warranty card that says
if you're broken show up at a doctor's
office and we'll fix you and that's got
the system all upside-down it's
backwards we're also required by law to
buy buy car insurance we're not required
by law to buy health insurance right
somewhat so under under Obamacare but I
mean practically speaking is this going
to bring down the cost of prescription
drugs definitely so here's how we think
about it people don't define their
health as a disease they define their
health as a barrier to living the life
they want to lead I'm a spinal cord
injury survivor
I don't describe myself that way but I
have neuropathy that gets in the way
pain that gets in the way of me living
the life I want to lead so what's the
question we should be asking about
health what is your what is it about
your health that gets in the way of you
living the life you want to lead and if
we understand that person by person we
can actually solve that problem it is
about prescription drug costs yep so
higher or lower under emerge early
prescription drug costs are just a small
part 15 to 20% of the equation we need
to look at the whole cost of care the
whole total therapy what is the best
solution
when sovaldi came out for hepatitis C we
solved that problem by just saying sure
we're gonna pay for it because it's the
other costs associated with Hep C are so
catastrophic it was better for us to get
people treated and cured the concern
with this merger is going back to your
car analogy is that basically what's
gonna happen is people are only gonna
have a choice between two cars and that
the lack of choice the consolidation
means prices might go down a little bit
at first but then you can't go anywhere
else new entrance to the market can't
happen what's the argument what's the
rebuttal there well why would people
only have two choices well because
you're making the the you're offering
them what their choices are so it's
totally up to you they can't they can't
make choices based on price they can
you're the only game in town
we can't force people at the CVS but if
it's the only if it's the only drug
store in town and that's where I'm
getting my health care but there are
plenty of drug stores in town so there's
Walgreens and there are independent
pharmacists and there are a whole host
of other pharmacy welcome say Amazon
getting into the business to compete
with you I think the more competition we
have the better it keeps the system
honest so there's not gonna be any
problem with with so they've they've
just got no case at all in terms of
these fears that there would be too much
consolidation it doesn't make sense for
CVS to turn off all their other
customers just for the 22 million Aetna
customers when they serve over 100
million people today well explain that
integration because what I've read about
what you think that CVS and Aetna can do
to debt together better so in in today's
environment sixty percent of our life
expectancy which has gone down two years
in a row is associated with where we
live 30 percent is our genetic code and
10 percent is the clinical care you
receive so now our zip code matters more
than our genetic code and how long we
love and unless we get into the
community and we begin to pride services
in the community that deal with issues
like social isolation food water
accessibility access if we can do more
of that in the community Inn near
people's homes
then we're gonna win because we're going
to keep people healthy around the issue
that prevents them from living the life
they want to lead so does that mean CBS
gives Aetna the storefront essentially
to do that the storefront becomes a
place call it 10,000 new front doors to
the healthcare system and what we want
to do is provide as many services as we
can in the community to meet social
determinants that's sixty percent versus
waiting for people to show up in the
healthcare system broken and fix them
and a benefit for CVS is I come in to
get a check in on my cold and I'm also
picking up products from CVS when I'm
going there for that other reason no
it's the it's the whole idea that if we
keep people healthier there's lower cost
in the system and when CVS is the
insurer that's an advantage for them
because they're getting the full premium
I get the premium dollar therefore if I
can reduce costs by keeping people
healthier we found this in Medicare
Advantage the more we invest in
individuals around their illnesses and
keeping them away from the health care
system the better off we are Mark
Bertolini be interesting to see these
changes thank you so much thank you yes
this morning good to see you